Hey, Vsauce. Michael here,
and today we're going to talk about
DONGS.
Things you can do online now guys.
First of all,
"danceromg577" brings up GogLogo.com
where you can make your own Google
looking home page with whatever text you
want.
Or be like the "Thetom5000" and take
control of the wheel of fortune board.
Make up the hint,
use underscores for blanks and
ta-da.
They actually look pretty good.
Atom.Smasher[.org] has a bunch of others,
like this marquee.
Then keep being sneaky like "cheseeh"
and sleuth around with no legs
as the man with the invisible trousers.
The surface you're on determines how
gravity
works, so use it to your advantage to get
to places you normally couldn't reach.
"MrsLilSensation" showed me 'Loved.'
A confrontational guide makes it uneasy
and being a good boy
or a good girl evolves the world
differently than being bad.
The humming drone in the background makes
it even more powerful.
But for something more puzzle based,
check out Tealy
and Orangey. The arrow keys control
each ball at the exact same time in the
same way,
but their worlds can be different, so watch out.
Now, if you want variety, try "NoTrollzAllowed's"
'I wanna win.'
Every level is a new type of puzzle.
Chess, search, a shell game,
brickbreaker, aiming.
It goes on and on and on. Speaking of variety,
"Left2Kill" showed off 'BoxCar2D,'
an evolution simulator similar to a screen
saver I once showed.
It's a sight where objects are randomly
generated and then left on a track
to see how far they move.
At the end of a generation
the computer takes the ones that moved
the furthest and combines them in random
ways,
like they're having kids.
You can alter the occurrence of mutations
and sit back, let it run and watch it try
to accomplish its goal -
a naturally selected impressive moving machine.
For more terror check out "tanos1998's"
and Dead Frontier Outbreak 2.
This text adventure test your wits.
Would you be able to make the right
decisions during a zombie apocalypse to
protect yourself
and save your wife?
Then relax and feed the head,
a big blue head you can feed, pull on, click on.
What's the point?
Well, who knows?
And how could I forget YouTube.com/cosmicpanda.
It's not a channel.
Instead, it's a place where you can toggle
into YouTube experiments.
There are some cool things like, for instance,
if you're on the Vsauce channel page
you can watch our explosion video
and boom. All of our other videos
are right there underneath,
ready to play one after the other.
And if you decide to go back to our channel
page
the video keeps playing.
It's still right up there
in the corner. And that's just one of a
bunch of cool experiments going on in
Cosmic Panda.
Try it out.
Let me know what you think.
"legoluke2000" has Oddcast's
text-to-speech site.
Their eyes follow your cursor
and they'll say whatever you type, which is
a perfect way to tell you to subscribe
to Vsauce,
so you're always up to date.
And as always,
thanks for watching.